good morning Hank it's actually a secret
reading in video nobody would have
guessed I don't think anyone was
confused our soap keeps selling out as
soon as we make it it's very good it's
re it's game changing I've leveled up my
soap games so much yeah that all the
things I was doing to the bath to try to
make my skin feel better turn out to be
unnecessary there's Willow who taught me
how to pack Socks today you know how
long it's been since we asked someone to
like or subscribe the weird thing is we
used to we dough all the time it's not
that I'm above it completely forgot I I
literally that lifestyle forgot to do it
for the last seven years we've been
between three and four million
subscribers for about 12 years so this
time I've decided to actually get some
real questions from real nerd providers
John this person asks have I ever
considered being a comedian I feel like
you should if you have it
Hank has considered being a comedian I
considered every one of the jobs that
you shouldn't try I just desperately
want to do everything once I'll tell you
what I've seen Hank bomb before not in
comedy but in music but really bomb it
was comedy music it's not that anyone
was listening nobody nobody found it
funny because nobody heard anything you
said I think you would be a good
comedian but I think it would take you
like 15 years to get a really good yeah
it takes it takes 15 years for everybody
to get really good yeah all these young
comedians who are popular now yeah
started when they were like 12. yeah
like Bo Burnham like of course he's
funny when he's 30. he started when he
was six oh he's very good but
unfortunately also so tall and handsome
but also intensely troubled which I
dodged
um you got to have that too yeah thank
you I don't know that you totally Dodge
intensity troubled I think that it might
be a kind of should be might be a sort
of late set intensely trouble you know
like some people you're not gonna look
over my shoulder some people get it too
like I did and some people get her to
43. you were historically less trouble
than really anyone I I wouldn't say
anyone I know but anyone I really adore
yeah
um but you've been a little more trouble
to think uh yeah I don't totally know
what's going on have you heard the
phrase bon vivant sure of course an
enjoyer of life I recently was exposed
to that phrase for the first time you'd
never heard the phrase maybe I'd heard
it but I didn't know what it was and you
realize that you are yourself a bond
Vivant aspiring oh okay you want that's
what you want to do when you grow up I
would like to have all of the parts of
worry that are good yeah without the
worry I need to have worried yes but I
don't want to be worried it's asking a
lot of verb tenses buddy I'm not sure
I'm not sure that they line up that way
I'll tell you one thing about bone
vivaldo yeah or is it a bad word I would
have said no and France isn't bad I
don't think so maybe but I usually
associate it with somebody who like
loves gluttony and eating and drinking
like that's so not you but I think we
should think of it as just a good wife
or somebody who's trying to have a good
life in every possible way I like that
definition a lot I actually wants to
know what my current favorite hyper
fixation is I have one what is it I
can't tell you oh it's a secret because
I'm gonna turn it into a project do I
know it yeah I send them to you
regularly oh yeah yeah do you have a
favorite musical and if so what is it of
all time Shrek two well okay I mean if
that's going to be how we're going to
Define musicals I guess for me it's
Penguins of Madagascar what do you put
in first cereal or milk and wine I can't
ask John this question because he's
going to talk to you about water and
cereal yeah you put the cereal in and
then you go over to the refrigerator and
you push the water button and the water
comes out oh the cold water that's great
for you and I you get the cornflakes
near Vivant I'm bonding my Vivant on
three Hank what's your favorite baseball
team one two three the Missoula battle
we went to a Missoula paddleheads game
yesterday it was wildly enjoyable it was
they wanted nature did a great job and
he had an ear and he went six strikeouts
in the first two innings we thought that
we might be in for a historic
performance where he struck out every
battery face but then when he didn't I
did kind of lose interest in the game I
was like wow it was very interesting
yeah he struck out the first six guys
and they were all like what is it like
watching your brother have to go to
meetings for all the companies you run
it's a little bit of both it's a little
bit of like
have a good time with the meetings it's
a little bit like oh god I've come to
appreciate the meetings I really have I
thought the question would surely be
what's it like watching your brother
have to go through something even worse
than meetings sometimes he does such a
good job not just with with the internet
but with us too of like being like Oh
it's not that bad but it is it really is
that bad the wild thing is that it's
kind of like I would describe it exactly
how people described it to me in terms
of like what chemo feels like right but
that doesn't mean that I knew what I was
gonna feel like it is it's super
stressful in addition to being scary and
sad and frustrating and unpleasant and
we are not going to add a butt to that
sound
you did have fun it would be this butt
the butt of a Corgi the sign thank you
to the UBS team they're doing great work
the mid cops and drop them they came and
went so fast so very impressive
okay can you tell that story real quick
yeah tell the story I went to uh In and
Out Burger the other day and a very nice
young man with slang are you who I think
you are and I said yes and he said man I
just want you to know that you know my
family and I are praying for you and uh
a really you know hope you pull through
I don't know what to say because I
wanted to take that I wanted to I wanted
to honor that person's well wishes you
know I said Thank you and I retell this
story to Hank and the first thing he
said was stolen valor
it was mine
all right John I'll see you next week